John Hein was on fire about the Emmys he
was upset about he's you know he's way
into TV he was upset that Game of
Thrones didn't get a directly with a
warden I go no Jason Bateman received a
Best Director in a Drama and he beat out
three episodes of Game of Thrones and I
said yeah something people could see
yeah Jason Bateman's smart he actually
put a light on when he shot the show I
I'm stunned I really am
why even if you didn't like the dark
episode is you guys call there are a
couple of dark episodes to other
episodes which were Fanta they're like
movies when I vote I vote for the guy
who lit the [ __ ] set I I call that
good directing I heard you were texting
JD during the entire Emmys angrily he
was tired of hearing from waiters like
where's he disagreed with he was like he
would keep text me get off the stage I'm
tired Here I am worth of bet Game of
Thrones because it won its fourth Emmy
for Best Drama right Dinklage is the
only actor in the entire show history
who is won an Emmy well that's wrong did
you go outside at all this week last
night we dinner at the pier on the
Hudson oh yeah very nice you upset that
you couldn't watch TV during that my
wife's like the Emmys are tonight right
she's like yeah she's like oh boy you
were also angry about the cast of veep
why are you angry with them okay so this
happened twice last night
so Game of Thrones they bring up the
whole cast for a tribute of sorts and
then they present whatever award they
did but they were honoring the fact that
the show ended right later in the show
they brought the cast of veep oh the
same thing right and I'm thinking like
why not do that for Big Bang Theory
probably the most successful comedy in
the lat that's ending why don't they get
to you're upset you know what it was why
America is great in other countries
they're looking for food because they
don't have food jobs Oh trust me I
understand where these problems relate
to the rest of the world I know you know
but I but you told me watching TV is
your cardio that's how you get